dc's movies have been hit and missed to
say the least and a few of them have
some real problems how did joss whedon
debase the flash which dc hero tried and
failed to get campy and what's up with
wonder woman 1984. keep watching to find
out
in the middle of a justice league fight
scene putting the titular superhero team
against steppenwolf and his pair of
demon forces a gag occurs that will jolt
most viewers right out of the movie
while running at super speed the flash
tackles wonder woman and when the dust
settles it's revealed that flash has
fallen face first onto her chest this
strange joke goes too far on countless
levels including the way it disrupts the
flow of the fight scene for an extended
gag that isn't funny enough to justify
its length it also reduces the lone
woman on the justice league team to just
her breasts for the sake of a little
slapstick the moment is emblematic of
how little wonder woman got to do in
this cut of the movie and as a cherry on
top justice league director joss whedon
had tried the same gag in avengers age
of ultron it's unclear why a joke that
was too much the first time around had
to be regurgitated here
the opening of jonah hex establishes a
bog standard origin story for the
titular superhero as the audience sees
his adversary quentin turnbull brand
hex's face and then burn down his house
with his wife and daughter inside hex is
left for dead but later revived by a
group of native americans the sequence
depicting this resurrection also
establishes that hex now has the ability
to temporarily resurrect dead people
himself in the comics though he doesn't
have any superhuman powers at all
there's nothing wrong with making tweaks
or even generous alterations to
long-established fictional comic book
characters when it comes to translating
them to the big screen this sequence
however arguably deviates too heavily
from the source material by bestowing
hex with supernatural gifts great
westerns are gritty and grounded by
action scenes populated by lifelike
characters but taking this more stylized
route and giving hex superpowers
challenges the genre in the wrong kind
of way and what does this whole new
direction accomplish pretty much nothing
with the film only making sporadic use
of hex's newfound abilities
every major superhero movie inevitably
ends with a big confrontation between
the hero and villain in the case of
2004's catwoman this is the battle
between the titular superhero and evil
cosmetics executive laurel herder the
problem with the sequence isn't that
it's offensive or thematically
inconsistent but simply that it tries
way too hard all throughout catwoman
seems like the infamous flirty
basketball game make it clear this is a
production that would love to be seen as
a campy good time the finale with very
grimly and toning lines like this is no
different
it's
overtime
unfortunately catwoman lacks the
creative unpredictability that defines
great pieces of camp arts like say the
rocky horror picture show or the works
of john waters those projects work
because they follow a unique creative
vision not a rigid blueprint for what
campy cinema should look like the latter
approach plays catwoman's final showdown
despite an abundance of cheesy lines and
the participation of camp queen sharon
stone the film's finale is dominated by
predictable action beats leaning so hard
into those elements delivers a climax
that's uncomfortably lackluster rather
than deliriously campy
as the original suicide squad film comes
to a close harley quinn is returned to
her prison cell only for the joker and
his goons to suddenly show up and break
her out of prison as alarm bells quite
literally ring joker embraces quinn and
remarks to her that it's time for them
to go home this romantic reunion is an
odd way to end an ensemble effort like
suicide squad since it narrows the focus
exclusively to quinn but it also goes
too far in sugarcoating the duo's toxic
relationship alterations to suicide
squad drawing reshoots and
post-production ended up cutting a
subplot involving quinn abandoning and
even beating up joker in favour of her
new comrades this development was
eschewed in favour of an ending that
leaves no room for moral ambiguity nor
any recognition of just how abusive the
joker's behavior has been it's tidy sure
but it fits neither the characters nor
their relationship and closes the movie
out on a note that leaves a bad taste in
the mouth
it's been discussed at nauseam by
everyone from comics writers to fans to
the cast and crew of the movie itself
even with this avalanche of discourse
however the snapping of zod's neck at
the end of man of steel still stands out
as a premier example of a dc comics
movie going too far at the end of the
film that launched the ill-fated snyder
verse superman is forced to choose
between killing zod or allowing him to
kill a group of innocent civilians the
hero opts for the former snapping zod's
neck and then proceeding to wail in
misery over killing the only other
surviving member of his species
[Applause]
the concept behind this moment isn't
inherently bad especially for a superman
origin story in execution though it
doesn't have much impact coming off a
lengthy sequence of endless fist
fighting between the two kryptonians how
can a neck snap compare to all of this
what's more neither the rest of man of
steel nor subsequent dc films pause for
any length of time to absorb the full
consequences of superman's actions at
this point you can't help but get the
feeling that superman was only made to
do this in order to stoke some fan
controversy
in alan moore and dave gibbons original
watchmen graphic novel the character of
rorschach makes a comment in his journal
suggesting that fellow hero ozymandias
might be gay this comment along with
other small details from the graphic
novel has led to widespread
interpretations of ozymandias being
queer director zack snyder ended up also
hinting at this orientation during his
watchmen film adaptation though his
interpretation of such a character trait
left a lot to be desired for starters
azimandiya says superhero costume is
distinctly different from the other
characters in the movie the outfits
textures and accentuated nipples on the
outfit evoking the superhero costumes in
the gel shoe marker batman movies whose
costumes are generally considered to
take cues from queer aesthetics more
egregious though is a moment in which
audiences glimpse ozymandias computer
and see a file labelled boys this detail
implying that watchman's central villain
is engaging in pedophilia continues a
troubling pop culture trend of
connecting this hideous act with
homosexuality snyder's previous movie
300 also had troubling details at coded
characters as villains solely based on
them exhibiting queer behavior it
therefore seems hard to accept that
these new additions to watchmen were a
coincidence though the concept of adrian
white being queer is not new the
watchmen movie's attempt to depict this
notion was unimaginatively distasteful
after being away from earth for years
it's understandable that clark kent
would want to check up on his loved ones
of course he could do the normal thing
people do in this situation like calling
up people you care about or maybe
checking out their social media pages
instead though superman opts to go to
lois lane's house float in the air a
short distance from it and use his x-ray
vision to see inside now he can observe
lane and her son and what their
day-to-day routine is like great right
it's just a shame that these poor mortal
human beings are totally oblivious to
the super-powered stalking going on
nearby this moment is too much in many
respects but it's especially rough in
that this was clearly thought of as a
perfect way to explore superman's sorrow
over being away from his loved ones for
so long surely there could have been
more effective ways of conveying this
attitude than via some light stalking it
makes superman a hero too powerful to
really be held accountable by anybody
seem creepy rather than inspiring or
even likeable this scene proved so
notorious in fact that 15 years later an
episode of superman and lois devoted an
entire subplot to the idea that using
superpowers to listen in on your family
is weird in this episode lois explicitly
mentions that superman had spied on her
years before and almost lost her as a
result
there's a lot going on in the third act
of batman v superman including the
introduction of doomsday and the debut
of wonder woman superhero persona but an
equally important if not immediately
noticeable development is that we
finally get insight into why lex luthor
hates superman when the kryptonian
confronts luther over kidnapping martha
kent luther begins to ramble about his
motivations which include him commenting
that no man in the sky intervened when i
was a boy to deliver me from daddy's
fists and abominations
this line indicates that luther suffered
from child abuse and that these
traumatic experiences fueled his hatred
for people like superman the lingering
after-effects of an abusive childhood is
a weighty issue to suddenly bring up in
the third act of a pg-13 superhero movie
there's nothing inherently wrong with
superhero films dealing with heavier
subject matter of course but the problem
is that at this point in the movie the
plot is about to shift its focus almost
entirely to no fewer than two cgi
showdowns there's no time to give this
revelation the weight and breathing room
it requires abruptly bringing it into
the fold as a way to explain why luther
is so evil simply derails batman v
superman's already complicated final act
the quest by maxwell lord to utilize the
wishing rock to the best of its
abilities in wonder woman 1984
eventually takes him across the world to
egypt to visit amir saad bin arbidos the
presence of this oil barren character
kicks off a deluge of astonishingly
tone-deaf stereotypes about people
hailing from the middle east and north
africa every scene set in egypt and
wonder woman 1984 even ones in which
arbidose is off screen are jaw-dropping
in their regressive portrayals of mena
individuals naturally such depictions
were bound to generate controversy as
well as a few thoughtful essays breaking
down how these scenes were so off the
mark one of the more insightful examples
of these breakdowns came in a piece for
slate where writer roxanna hadidi broke
down some of the worst cultural
misconceptions in wonder woman 1984.
these include characters referring to
arbidose as your highness despite egypt
being a democracy in the 1980s as well
as the ways in which arbidose's costume
resembles traditional attire from saudi
arabia or the united arab emirates
rather than egypt such inaccuracies feed
into dehumanizing stereotypes of mena
individuals it appears that wonder woman
1984 a film that seeks to celebrate the
cinema of the 1980s was unable to escape
the racial caricatures that was so
rampant in that era there are countless
things audiences could have been
expecting to see in wonder woman 1984
but surely nobody was expecting a
weirdly dismissive approach to sexual
assault this shocking development
emerged in a scene in which diana prince
discovers that her wish on the wishing
rock has come true steve trevor has come
back to life rather than just having
trevor resurrected in his original body
though the film has trevor inhabit the
body of a total stranger with trevor
back from the dead he and prince proceed
to have sex which should be a passionate
romantic reunion takes on all kinds of
unsettling tones however given that it
involves a sexual partner who cannot and
did not consent to be involved wonder
woman 1984 never addresses these
disturbing implications and simply plows
ahead on its story about wishes getting
more and more out of control
understandably this storytelling detour
inspired an outcry when the movie was
released tragically reflecting how even
modern blockbusters can fall prey to
problematic tropes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you